Speaker 1: Speaking of Trump and Trouble. The
debt Trump is scheduled to be deposed today.
The backstory on this is that throughout his
presidency, all sorts of complaints were made.
Legal complaints were made against Trump.
Many of them for sexual assault allegations.
But the whole point of Trump's being president
was, among other things, to say Oh no, no, no,
I'm too busy being president to actually be
deposed. And the records need to be kept secret.
Executive privilege, all these different things.
This may very quickly be changing. Donald Trump
faces a pile of civil lawsuits as depositions
begin. Listen to this! Trump is defending himself
in at least 10 civil suits alleging fraud and
defamation to incitement of violence. Former
President Trump has been ordered to answer
questions under oath in a lawsuit today, and
his attorneys could set a date for a deposition
in another case as well. The lawsuits involving
allegations that his security guards roughed
up protesters outside Trump Tower in New York
and allegations of defamation by former
Apprentice contestant Summer Zervos,
respectively, are just two cases in the mass of
civil litigation. Trump faces post-presidency At
least 10 civil cases are pending against Trump,
whose ability to delay them has been curtailed
since he left office in January. Trump has argued
in some of the cases that as a sitting president,
he was immune from civil lawsuits. His office
didn't respond to a request for comment on the
cases. Here's a rundown of the major civil suit
where the major civil suits stand. So you've got
Summer Zervos? That's a name we've talked
about before. She's been pushing for this
for years and hopefully now it's actually going
to happen. Zervos was a contestant on Season five
of The Apprentice. Says Trump smeared her
by calling her a liar during his campaign
in 2016, after she accused him of having
subjected her to unwanted kissing and groping
when she was seeking career advice in 2007.
An attorney for Trump declined to comment.
Trump's attorneys have said that his statements
were true and they plan to file a countersuit.
Protesters at Trump Tower also Monday, attorneys
for protesters who alleged Trump's bodyguards
assaulted them during a demonstration in 2015 were
set to question Trump. Trump said in an affidavit
in 2016 he doesn't know anything about it. He
wasn't directly involved in hiring security. His
attorneys tried to spare him from testifying
for years, including when he was president.
But the judge now said his testimony was
indispensable. The videotaped deposition was being
conducted inside Trump Tower, where six protesters
were demonstrating in September of 2015, and they
would be used as testimony when the case goes to
trial. You've also then got E! Jean Carroll suing
Trump for defamation that may require Trump to be
deposed and give testimony that was transferred to
federal court last year after the Justice
Department sought to intervene, saying No,
no, no. Trump's immune because the statements
are part of his official responsibilities,
there's going to be arguments heard in December.
There could be deposition dates set their
business investors. I mean, this is this could be
a decade for Donald Trump. Trump, his children,
Eric, Don Jr. and Ivanka and his company are also
being sued in the same court house by a group
of people who say the family conned them into
making bad investments in businesses the Trumps
were promoting. That's another one that could
lead to depositions. Mary Trump, Trump's niece,
alleges the family defrauded her out of millions
of dollars from her grandfather's estate
and allegedly involving Donald Trump. So that
one's going on. And then January 6th. Trump has
been hit with at least four lawsuits by Democratic
lawmakers and Capitol Police officers over the
Jan. six riots. Trump attorneys maintain he is
immune. He was president at the time. The speech
that allegedly incited the riot was protected
by the First Amendment. We want cases dismissed
and depositions have not yet been scheduled.
There's also some voting rights related claims,
which could lead to depositions at some point in
time. This is a crazy amount of stuff now. Even if
Trump successfully manages to beat off having
to be deposed in the vast majority of these,
this is an unconscionable amount of legal bills.
Now these are really legal bills which Donald
Trump should have to pay personally. You know,
this is a topic where we've seen Matt Gates use
campaign funds to cover legal expenses early on
now in the possible upcoming charges against him.
Would there really be consequences to Trump if he
uses that grifter money supposedly raised to fight
election fraud to pay for legal expenses? I don't
know. I know, I know you're not allowed to do it,
and it's against federal election law. But
there have not exactly been repercussions
to many members of Congress and various
politicians for doing that using donated funds for
personal legal expenses. So I don't really know.
It wouldn't shock me that Trump tries to do it,
and it wouldn't shock me if Trump gets away with
it, quite frankly. So we're going to continue
monitoring that. And in the midst of all this,
Donald Trump is now asking you to donate $45
to him to fight election fraud, which if
you fall for it at this point, I mean,
you're really disconnected from reality, but
we'll talk about that a little bit tomorrow.
We'll take a quick break. After the break.
We're going to talk about Ted Cruz's latest
statements about the Australian COVID guidelines,
which by and large have worked very well.
We're going to talk about the resurrection,
not not the wrong term, right? The resurrection
of the war on Christmas. And we've got
much more upcoming after this short break